well let me ask you this because you
said
controversially not really that uh
viruses are not living
um
defend yourself
so our virus is alive or not so i've
seen many people say oh they have to be
they
they have nucleic acids they evolve they
mutate
that's all true but they don't do it on
their own the particles in my mug are
just not doing any of that unless they
get into a cell so a virus infected cell
is alive i totally agree with that
because in fact when a virus gets in a
cell it converts it into a virus-making
factory if you will it's no longer a
cell it's a some people call it a viral
cell i don't really like that but it's
fine
so that's what i'm talking about the
particle is not alive you can have your
virus infected cell as as alive but the
particle it just would not do anything
forever without getting inside of a cell
well once it's in the cell
it it is alive then but it's no longer a
particle it's taken apart and nucleic
acid is moving around the cell it's
making proteins eventually it makes new
particles and then those particles
released from the cell they're not
living anymore so it's kind of i think
it's kind of like a spore a spore of a
uh
or a seed
although the seed just doesn't work
because the seeds
the cells in the seed have the ability
to make their own energy and so forth
but a bacterial spore and it's the same
thing doesn't do anything unless you add
water and nutrients and then it starts
to divide but it doesn't need to get
into a cell it's very different from a
virus so that's why the particle
and when people think of virus
they're always thinking of the particle
and that's why i say it can't be alive
because the particle can't do anything
on its own but if you think of a virus
as an organism with a particle phase and
a part in a cell then it makes sense to
be alive
and by the way when you say particle
you're referring to that structure that
you've been mentioning something right
membrane and not that that's that's been
called what is a viron particle or
something
so what you should have here i'll send
you one and then you can refer to what's
the sexiest one to have like what what
in terms of particles that have on the
table
well unfortunately the ones that you can
3d print
oh they're not going to be so they're
they're only the ones that we know the
structures of right so someone sent me
last year a 3d model of source cov2 and
it's beautiful it's actually cracked
open so you can see the rna and the
spikes are sticking out and they even
put some antibodies sticking onto the
spikes and that's i mean
when i show this on a live stream people
love this thing oh my god that's
beautiful it is it's absolutely gorgeous
i have that i have my virus that i
worked on most of my career polio virus
i have a 3d model of that which i
actually just had made it's gorgeous and
you can have it made in any color you
want right
you